at the 2000 Republican National
Convention the country got one of its
first glimpses of a new type of public
charter school the slogans of our
schools are not all of us can learn but
rather all of us will learn the claim
was that with enough rigor and devotion
such schools could close the achievement
gap between poor minorities and their
wealthy white counterparts there are no
shortcuts
you're here at 7:25 you stay until 5:00
you suffer through two hours of homework
you come on Saturdays you come during
the summer the shining example was the
knowledge is power program or Kipp it's
a public school unlike just about any
you have seen before there's no more
excuses the school down the block can no
longer say well what can we do but
skeptics pointed out that the family
showing up at Kipp and other no excuses
charters were self selected charter
schools by definition are not random
collections of students students who
choose to go to charter schools are
likely to have more motivated parents
every student every parent and every
teacher must commit to Kip's regimen of
long hours and hard work in writing in
2006 a combative former New York City
Council member named Eva Moskowitz
co-founded a new charter school network
with the same approach I think parents
deserve in real time something better
Success Academy was kept on steroids
trouncing many public schools and
wealthy neighborhoods on the annual
state exams enter the education writer
and former public school teacher Robert
pend Issa who spent a year embedded at a
Success Academy in an effort to figure
out just how these schools do it in his
new book how the other half learns
Pandya reports that the critics were
right not only is the very act of
applying to the lottery self-selecting
but Success Academy makes such rigorous
demands on parents that it
disproportionately retains the most
highly motivated families and that
dissatisfaction brought as many as 5,000
parents to the armory in Washington
Heights the result is that an
applicant's chances of winning a seat at
success in its annual high-stakes
lottery are
competitive as many had claimed Bundy Co
found that there are about six
applicants for every spot
however because so many families drop
out the chances of getting offered a
spot are actually closer to 50% but for
those that make the commitment the
impact is transformative and he argues
that these kids deserve the same access
to a great school that upper middle
class parents finagle for their children
even if it means leaving the rest of
their communities behind let's be
brutally honest when you take that child
away you're damaging the public school
system but where do we get the right to
treat anybody's child as a public
resource i sat down with Pandey Co to
discuss why he believes motivated
families deserve the opportunity to exit
their district public schools which the
New York Times reviewer called a morally
disturbing conclusion to his unsparingly
on his book and his challenge to both
supporters and detractors of the school
reform movement Robert Bundy so thanks
for talking to Reason thanks for having
me let me start with the question who is
Tiffany and why does she matter ah you
can try to make me emotional first
question huh
Tiffany was a student in my second year
of teaching at PS 277 in the South Bronx
and this was a little girl who I like to
just you know tell this story she would
come to school every day in her uniform
the building could fall down and Tiffany
would be behind her her desk scribbling
away and when I pointed out to my
special ed supervisor at the time that
look I've got this kid I'm not doing
anything for her I'm basically ignoring
her and she said verbatim quote she's
not your problem meaning you know why
are you focusing your attention why you
concerned at all about Tiffany she's
delivering the results we need but at by
the same token this was a kid who was
deeply bought into what we were doing so
she ended up moving to Pennsylvania
graduating from a perfectly fine State
University but I've been troubled for
the last 15 years like what could this
kid have been if she were in one of
these so-called no excuses charter
schools where you know she was pushed to
go not just to college but to a terrific
College you know the ultimate
achievement gap in American life is in
test scores it's the leadership gap you
know we'd all be working for this kid
with her incredible work at it so you
know the thesis of your
is that Success Academy is the type of
school for the Tiffany's of the world
yeah I think that's right so are the
success schools actually a random
lottery are they random
how does had a success yeah this is
complicated but it's worth unpacking the
moment a parent raises his or her hand
and says I want a charter school instead
of the neighborhood default public
school I would argue that parent is
almost instantly setting himself or
herself apart from the parent who
exercises no choice whatsoever you're at
least curious about what else is out
there so describe the average success
parent then yeah and and again I'm gonna
keep saying this but this is also
anecdote not right not data because the
data is just not available to my
knowledge so I spent a year embedded in
a in a school in in the South Bronx
literally across the street before I was
a student teacher and in the same
neighborhood where I taught Tiffany and
others I went in a fifth or a second
grade field trip at one point and I
promise you I'm not making this up there
were more dads chaperoning that field
trip that I saw in five years of
parent-teacher conferences in my old
school observably every morning you see
father's you see a couples married
couples or at least cohabitating couples
dropping their kids off so a pattern
emerges and I got to know quite a few
parents and the way I describe it they
are over-represented married employed
almost invariably religious and/or
spiritual ambitious for their children
what's the level of minority 101 okay so
this is and you're not describing people
who are you know a kind of double income
highly professional white Asian yeah
it's not gonna happen in some other
neighborhoods with Success Academy it
certainly is but the school that I was
teaching or embedding in in the South
Bronx is is is not really gentrifying at
this point the way other neighborhoods
in New York City are and you success
will say what is it it's something like
or you know where it seems that for
every slot at success there's what
something like forty students or you
know there was six to one there are six
more applicants for every seat then
entering the lottery then then
ultimately end up getting place why is
that a misleading well because and this
is take someone packing to the the
enrollment lottery is the first step in
the process once you so let's say this
is from memory I think there were
something like 17,000 applicants for
3,000 seats the year that I was in
success 3,000 are immediately seated and
are told congratulations you're in 7000
are told sorry no room at the end as it
were the rest which is another six or
seven thousand are placed on a so called
likely list remember that term likely
and this was all random assignment
absolutely 100% random so then the next
step is you're invited to a welcome
meeting which is kind of a little bit
scared straight I mean to success
academies credit they could not be more
clear about what they stand for and what
they will not stand for like they they
will say the one person who I quoted the
book said this is not Burger King you
don't get to have it your way
there are uniforms that these are the
hours we will suspend your kid as early
as kindergarten if they break our rules
etc so they could not be more clear or
emphatic about their school culture that
scares some folks away or if you don't
show up to the Welcome meeting and you
don't reschedule then you were dropped
then comes to confirm your interest
email then comes a uniform fitting day
then comes a dress rehearsal for
kindergarten at every step along the way
some number fall away and and we don't
know why perhaps there are a lot of
other charter schools they decide no I'd
rather go to that one than this one but
at the end of the day what's undeniable
is that your chances of getting in are
closer to one in two and because of this
kind of aggressive acculturation that
goes on during this process my thesis on
this and I think success somewhat
disagrees with this is you end up with a
parent body of either true believers or
those who are willing to have their
their parenting kind of molded a little
bit because because success makes
prodigious demands on parents you're
gonna read to your kids six books a week
you're gonna check the homework you're
gonna fill out the reading logs you got
to drop your kid off every morning by
7:30 you got to pick your kid up every
day it's I think 3:45 Wednesday's a half
day 12:30 there's no after-school
there's no transportation and again I
don't want to paint the picture that
this is being done deliberately to to to
to call the her notice
but as a practical matter it's just
easier to comply with these cool culture
demands if you've got the bandwidth of
two parents or at least a support
network well you've got somebody so if
you're living at kind of chaotic
disorganized life it's just kind of hard
to do that
yeah so and so this all goes towards
your thesis really that they're not
creaming students yes to get and we'll
talk about the the results and how good
people who go through the Success
Academy seem to be doing but that
they're creaming the parents yeah and
you know I'll be honest Nick I wish I
hadn't framed it that way that they are
creaming or cherry-picking parents
because at the end of the day those
parents are creaming or cherry-picking
themselves right my more nuanced point I
hope is that it's it's not oh it's the
parents stupid
it's the conditions the cultural
condition the school culture conditions
that that self-selection sets in motion
look you know if you have a just so
school culture with that is a high
expectations very demanding etc you
can't impose that on people you know you
have to at least start with those who
want it or those who are willing to to
have their efforts directed so in other
words this simply would not work to
impose this on my old school or almost
any other school so it's a more
complicated thing than it's the parents
it's it's the starting line it creates
the the buy-in and that's the key idea
that makes this this level of rigor and
high expectation doable is Success
Academy representative of the Charter
movement as a whole or successful
schools as a whole that's a really great
question I mean and I don't think I have
a firm conclusion about this I think I
asked the question in the book because
the entire idea of IDI reform for the
last 20 odd years has been you know if
you have the right conditions every
child can can learn at a high level
success academies results are so
unusually good that it raises the
question is this a proof point or is
this kind of the reverse perfect storm
that in its relative rarity proves that
this really is not you know widely do it
well now what you're talking about is
different than the way that Eva
Moskowitz talks about what success does
um and she says look our model will work
for 99.9 percent of kids that it is the
school that's transformational not
things that are happening before and
after and things like that uh you know
other than that they do their homework
is that just wrong Wow
I mean who might have disagreed with Eva
Moskowitz I mean she's created this
fantastic network of schools and I'm
just you know some guy who sat in them
but yeah I kind of disagree with that or
in other words the proof point there
would be will then take 99% 99.9% of
students and they don't do that and you
know this puts me in an awkward position
because at the end of the day I'm
strongly supportive of what they do but
I just don't think that that's what
they're doing
because if that is what you were doing
then you wouldn't put those hurdles in
front of kids you would just you do the
opposite you take the first hundred kids
in the door and you'd fight like hell to
keep those 100 kids in the door so it's
it's weird to me to think that you know
on the one hand you say that you can do
this with 99.9% of kids but you have
these structures in place that and again
I'm defending this that allow parents
ourself sort if that's your theory then
wouldn't you want to prove that you can
do this with every child so I mean
that's an argument that success Academy
is really not representative of the
Charter move of the schools that are in
the Charter movement because I think
that's right okay and and could you
disarrange could you contrast maybe
briefly you teach at a school called
democracy prep what is its guiding ethos
and is it as successful as success
academy what do you mean by successful I
don't really go with the option to well
define success downward sure this is
this is why we could talk about this
till the cows come home the way we keep
score and I'm using that phrase not
success the measure of the the standard
measure of performance is test scores I
have a complicated relationship with
test scores I don't think that they are
necessarily the alpha and they're
certainly not the Alpha and Omega and
there's other things and I'd like to
look at as well so by rights I should
probably intensely dislike what I saw at
success because to be brutally blunt
they put test-prep on steroids even the
the curriculum is arguably even a bit
test preppy when it's not test prep
season yet I got to the end of this
experience and I found myself saying but
you know I
like what I'm seeing here and and at the
end of the day I think it had more to do
with what I what my bet would be their
long-term outcomes and I described this
at some length in the book there is
simply nothing in the experience or
history for a low-income family of color
in this country to expect a good
relationship with a place called a
school I mean it's like the school where
I taught I mean it's where you go to see
how little is expected of you what what
your how narrow your horizons are so
even though I don't like necessarily
that they are test prepping kids at the
wazoo it adds up to something powerful
so think of this you know you're in a
school and you're a ten year old kid and
the test that's that you're being
prepared for nobody's telling you it's
easy quite the opposite they're telling
you it's hard you were surrounded by
adults who are pushing you you know it's
a tough love culture they're calling
your parents every night to say how
you're doing on the most recent test the
practice tests and then lo and behold
the testing day comes along and not only
do you do well you do really well you do
better than kids in Scarsdale and
Jericho on Long Island so think what
that means you're now growing up in an
environment where I'm good at school
everybody I know is good at school my
parents are in on it my their parents
are in on it I think it just changes the
temperature so in a way I'm not even
sure Moskowitz thinks about it this way
but while I don't necessarily like the
testing culture I think it's a bit of a
game changer if I can use that cliche in
terms of the relationship that a kid
feels like they're having with their
school like oh I'm good at this this is
gonna take me someplace and one would
assume that general odds are one would
hope that generalizes beyond school I
think well yeah if I can accomplish this
I can do other things but not only that
I mean the way I like to say this is the
first and most impactful or first most
important relationship a child has with
the Civic institution in this country is
almost invariably with the school as
that one goes so goes the other all the
others you know there's a review of your
book and the New York Times ultimately
said that you produced a morally
disturbing conclusion to an unsparingly
honest book part of the morally
disturbing conclusion is that this is
not for all people is that morally
disturbing to you you can
look at a kid like Tiffany and say well
you know we need her in this failing
school because she's a good role model
to the other kids etc and when you take
that child away and send her to a
charter school you're damaging the
public school system well you are let's
be brutally honest I mean this is
something we're not supposed to say in
ed reform but is it and and and there's
data that suggests it's not true but as
a teacher I know if you take Tiffany and
three or four other kids like that out
of my South Bronx classroom my job is
harder not easy don't don't tell me that
this is somehow gonna benefit me I would
argue it is equally morally disturbing
to not allow those who are ready you
know to be upwardly mobile to be fully
and well educated it's it's morally
troubling that we deny that I mean my
frame for this is where do we get the
right to treat anybody's child as a
public resource in a sense what about
those other kids you know I mean are
they you know do we just kind of write
them off no no and also related to this
is the question of like is school
actually that transformational because
part of the presumption of all of these
debates is that you know school is what
matters not all of these other things it
can be more transformational than it is
for for more students certainly and
again I come back to the Tiffany example
school was insufficiently
transformational perhaps what's in 20
years we might have a different
conversation the part of this book that
frankly my ed reform colleagues should
not like is is where I take that idea so
you know there's been a strong strain of
thought for years among defenders of
traditional public schools you can't
compare these two things you can't
compare the results of a traditional
public school and a charter school and
it's unfair and my answer is well that's
right
it is unfair but in the same way that it
does not follow from that that therefore
we should not allow choice it does not
follow from that that we should tell the
traditional public schools you should
get as good a results as these schools
with self-selected parents so if
anything that's an argument for perhaps
more resources better training etc for
for some folks in those schools but but
we have to acknowledge that they have
when they say our job is harder there
lying your job is harder let's you know
focus a bit on the idea that it's
morally troubling to allow certain
people to escape a sinking boat or a
listing ship you know that is just not
going anywhere is can you you people who
make that argument is it equally morally
troubling to say no you know what the
real the morally good solution is to you
know keep everybody in a boat that's not
going anywhere or sinking right but Nick
nobody says that to me nobody says that
to you I mean this is but isn't that the
argument when people say you know we got
it we got a reduce school choice because
it lets people who are motivated to take
advantage of those choices get better
outcomes look there's a big iron eight
lurking in the room here which is if you
are affluent white whatever you have
de-facto school choice right now if you
have the means to pay private school
tuition or Catholic school tuition you
can do that if you don't you can at
least pick up and move to you know
Scarsdale or Greenwich or somesuch where
your property taxes are functionally
your private school tuition let's be
really candid about that so if this is
your theory of change then you need to
explain why this is a problem for black
and brown people only in other words
when Eva Moskowitz comes up with a way
to give a low-income black and brown
families the the functional level of
choice that I have that you have well
then why is that a problem why is it
only a problem when somebody does it for
them it hasn't been a problem for
decades and for the rest of us so
somebody smarter than me needs to
explain how you can live with with with
those two opposing ideas in your head in
the Wall Street Journal you wrote that
both sides are of the school choice of
it are forced to be dishonest yeah in
arguments both for and against charter
schools resorting to aspirational
politically pleasing narratives about
what it takes to improve outcomes for
disadvantaged children
if charter school or school choice
proponents are basically lying about the
role that schools play in most people's
lives that's a problem I don't think
it's doublet of public school
traditional public school supporters and
teachers unions are saying like we can
do this we just need more and more
resources that seems to be alive or
or misleading I think it's a politically
necessary lie I mean I don't like
accusing people of lying but I think
it's the the practical politics here
demand that we be dishonest about that
in other words support for charter
schools would probably suffer if they
were perceived as a sorting mechanism as
you know the so-called poor man's
private school support for public
schools traditional public schools would
probably suffer if we were honest and
say look we really can't do this for
every child right now I don't have a
good answer for this to be blunt the
only thing I can offer is we talk all
the time as teachers about meeting the
children where they are it might be
helpful to start talking about meeting
families where they are you know the
family that is that is drawn to a
success Academy or another
high-performing charter school that does
their due diligence that has that level
of investment and buy and they're in a
different place in their in their
American trajectory as it were then a
family you know that is that is
suffering from any number of you know a
parent in jail unemployment drug
addiction etc one of the things I think
we do incorrectly in this work is we
tend to view urban communities through
you know what I would call twin lenses
of dysfunction we either assume that
everybody is broken and there are no
families like the ones that are drawn to
to a Success Academy or we assume that
those who who are married employed
religious ambitious for their children
we said we assume like I was told with
Tiffany they're not your problem which
is horribly condescending I mean either
one of those is terribly condescending
but we don't really differentiate enough
can we talk uh so briefly you know one
of the knocks on Success Academy in
particular is that it's brutal you know
not just a parent yes I like okay you
got to be doing your kids homework every
night you got to make sure they're
reading all these books you got to show
up when we yet you know pick them up
drop them off all of this type of stuff
but that they were literally brutal to
the kid there and and you know there's a
kind of viral footage of a teacher
berating a little kid yeah did you see
any of that sort of stuff and this is
where I think we have really done dirt
to Moskowitz and Success Academy now
look I'm not offended by the site
of kids marching in two lines in
elementary school I'm not offended by
the idea that kids should set up pay
attention make eye contact and look if
you take nothing else away from this
book and spending time at Success
Academy
you cannot mistake the deep authentic
investment that that teachers have in
kids so very quickly say what is the
thing that Ed reformers who are kind of
Pro you know uncritically or or maybe
not so critically in favor of charter
schools and in favor of Success Academy
what did they have to take away from
this and for traditional defenders of
traditional D actuals what is what's the
the main point that they really need to
grab it's a great question and and at
the risk of oversimplifying I think we
really have to focus on school culture
in other words it's not enough testing
isn't enough even the sorting if you
want to call it that isn't enough kids
learn better when they are in an
environment that valorizes achievement
if that's what you're trying to get high
achievement and that's really it's
almost impossible for public policy to
account for because we don't allow
parents as a general rule to self sort
we don't allow absent of out your system
parents to pick a school culture that
works for them so if school culture
really is the thing that drives
achievement that's a that's a prodigious
challenge for the ED policy world how do
we make that possible would you agree
that there's a large concerted push back
against charter so understand and as
part of that related to them over
selling their impact no I think it's
pure political expedience honest so what
what are the forces there well I think
you know if you look at you know III I
work for a policy shop but I'd you know
I'm not really the best policy guy I'm
more of an instructional guy but it's
unmistakable that if you look at the run
up to the 2020 election the the
Democrats who are you know what the
white house seemed to fall into two
camps those who are opposed to charter
schools and those who are really opposed
to charter schools so you know the by my
demands that by talking some of them
talk about I'm against for-profit
charter schools which are a negligible
amount of charter school yeah you know I
I don't I'm not invested in a frankly to
even parse the differences what I know
is that it's its descend this
advantageous to to you know low income
kids of color who have the
right now to take advantage of these
environments and it's just frankly just
weird to me that we have this category
of school that has been making a
difference for some number of them and
that at least one party is you know is
seems eager to throw them under the bus
how do you evaluate whether or not you
know this particular choice model or
this particular choice is worth kind of
pursuing I will admit that I have a
fairly unsophisticated view of whether
or not choice works here's how I view it
did you get to choose do you like your
choice